elles sont drôles touchantes émouvante
percutante poignante controversé
provocante
je parle des caricatures de serge
chapleau depuis 50 ans lit à travers ces
caricatures on peut presque retracer
toute notre histoire
il crée des images de position de
personnages publics y resterons jamais à
jamais gravé dans nos mémoires
regardez ça c'est gérald robbie fowler
de chevreuil devant ce qui lui arrive
écoutez ceci stéphane dion en sourigues
celle là on va s'en souvenir longtemps
longtemps longtemps et puis voilà
jean chrétien et d'autres votre
caricature bah oui vous s'échappent
lopar chapleau ici puisque c'est la page
couverture de son livre magistral publié
un lien aussi avec une exposition au
musée mccord toute sécurité sur
regroupés selon les thèmes des chapitres
de sa vie s'échappe l'eau depuis ses
débuts j'en parle avec lui serge
chapleau bonsoir moi ça va très bien
vous aussi qu'est ce que ça vous fait de
revoir votre vie à travers tous ces
caricatures
ça fait cinquante sur le prénom même
pour moi j'ai l'impression quand on a
préparé le livre parce qu'on préparer
l'exposition en même temps et qovu
d'oublier le livre est pour sortir en
même temps que l'explosion mais qu est
ce qui fait qu on étire de tarder
beaucoup mais j'ai quand même très
contente de 18 ans c'est assez
particulier de tourner de l'entente 6 50
ans d'histoire à travers les petits
bonhommes j'ai trouvé ça quand même et
corée après vous être à découvert dont
vous êtes surpris vous même
oui oui en même temps je me rappelle mon
corps ne me fait un peu limité lui menti
mandela question refaire une exposition
puis la question que j'ai posée ici est
ce que je devrais me l'ont dit avant
wall élections on m'a dit qu'avant ça
c'est le maillot vieux fusil vous avez
refusé encore leur talent et protester
évidemment la question vous la posera
souvent j'imagine au cours de ces
prochaines semaines parce que les gens
vont regarder
ils ont vraiment parfois pleurer l'ayant
robin williams absolument touchant même
un jean guy moreau mais d'autres qui ne
font mourir de rire
c'est ce que vous demandez ce qui vous
rend le plus fier ou la vidéo de
questions et compressé fait que c'est
impossible
j'ai l'impression en ciment qui s est
d'avoir je suis le moindre les toffies
d'avoir été là tout le temps je suis je
meurs je me prends comme le chien de
garde ainsi sa teinte démocratie j'étais
la femme a tout le temps les politiciens
passent puis le quelqu'un tu sais quand
même pas l épaule et s'est passé vous
demande sans doute les originaux parce
qu'ils sont très fiers c'est ça car
élèves pas où elles arrivent assez
régulièrement je me souviens d'un temps
où tu débuts dans le temps pour thomas
minsante des années soixante dix je
dessinais des vedettes des personnalités
du québec dont je tairai les noms de
certains mais qui m'envoyaient des
photos en disant fais ma casquette jaune
parce que quand époque à thury de base
un journal dans un magazine que tu
n'existes pas par contre après avoir
fait parce que vous avez des échos parce
qu'en plus dans ce livre on y retrouve
les présentations de blessures des
policiers je pense à madame marois
lucien bouchard jean charest mais alors
c'est très certainement et s'entendent
tous sur l'art l'art de la caricature
qu'est ce qui fait que ça devrait être
un art très noble la caricature le
monôme de journaux revues à notre large
et où exactement seulement populaire
j'ai l'impression que ça a toujours
existé la caricature maintenant le temps
des bons grands loi je me souviens d'une
anecdote assez incroyablement silencieux
wee 15 8 14
il y avait une tête en plus en forme de
poids il ya un quelques uns sur les
français qu'il dessinait notre
transformation jusqu'à temps qu'il a de
nouveau les poires c'était vraiment quel
gachi may a passé six mois en prison
alors c'est probablement une bonne paie
j'ai pas le goût d'aller en prison fait
que j'essaye de faire attention quand on
dit voilà de décrire notre histoire que
quand on regarde
la femme de vos oeuvres année après
année parce que vous publiez aussi des
ouvrages vos caricatures de l'année la
vallée court désespérément qu'ally
madame plantes sur celui là vous
pourriez la sphère imac qui va enerplan
oui c'est ça maintenant j'en ai
plusieurs le savoir pour les poches et
libanais plein des vallets quand et
toute nouvelle mais encore la caricature
et pères et les mères avec des cônes
orange elle s'est seulement tous les
politiciens assument vieille ligne de
quelques as tu ris mais on pense
toujours quelques indicateurs ici tout
seul dans son studio à travailler seule
semaine faisait la malle fonds aidera y
avait des sculpteurs de moustiques sont
très drôles on appelle ça des policiers
et ils sont prêts il faudrait voir mais
il faut les aimer ces gens là mais je
peux pas vous laisser partir un mot
quand même sur vos collègues
caricaturiste qui ont perdu la vie dans
l'attentât charlie-hebdo d'autres
témoignent qui ont survécu un mot sur
eux sur sept ce drame c'est une grande
grande tristesse et je lis physicienne
de continuer tout ce qu'il faut garder
de gabela d'un de contourner sexistes
incroyable des fous de dieu qui sont
allés lui plaît s'il ya encore des
quatre français dont quelques-uns que je
connais un peu disent qu'ils ont de
l'affection pour attirer quotidienne
encore sédentaires 200 m dos exactement
c'est une grande tristesse 7 c'est
épouvantable mais il reste une chose à
la barre des 24
il faut que la caricature il faut que ça
soit quelque part aux médias sa phase
avec les chiens il ya eu des dessins de
mahomet qui ont été publiés que te
d'après mme entrer en finale
mais quand une bonne analyse mais moi
j'avais mes seuls à feu la meilleure
intervenants être pas des années c'est à
mahomet qui sont sûrs et vient de la
terre d'en bas sur les nuages des
équipes et des gens pour ce qu'ils ont
fait exploser ou non mais d'ici à l'été
à l'été une demande de vieilles bâtisses
beaucoup cherchent à flot alors
l'exposition mes cordes et et ce
catalogue littéralement de l'oeuvre de
votre vie bonne continuation vous
gardent longtemps longtemps et merci
c'est gentil